this week on brian ross investigates
hello from ukraine everybody woke up to
some sad but unsurprising news
tick tock millions around the world are
getting their news and some gripping
videos from ukraine from a small group
of so-called influencers on the tip talk
app
the current situation in ukraine is dire
my family is there including my 57 year
old uncle my aunt and my nine-year-old
cousin
so i posted at the beginning of the war
a video of my little cousin my
nine-year-old cousin who was at the time
was in kiev and was sleeping under a
makeshift bed
in a bathtub with a mattress overhead
22 year old aaron parnez has been
briefed by the white house and supports
president biden even as his father is
under investigation for working with
rudy giuliani to dig up dirt on the
biden family it's
different times different positions and
i love my father but i'm not my father
plus corporate citizenship hundreds of
american companies have pulled out of
russia in the wake of the invasion but
many well-known companies are staying
put
a mass exodus of major international
companies is underway in russia we'll
meet the yale professor keeping track of
all of them ceos don't want to be on his
bad list the idea of these sanctions is
to put pain onto the economy we're not
we're not trying to figure out how to
advance the russian economy right now
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of mediaite
i have to be honest
i'm a little embarrassed that i'm even
talking about this right now from the
studios of the law and crime trial
network in new york city's herald square
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague rhonda schwartz
and ronda we begin with the power of
tick tock millions of people around the
world are now getting their news about
ukraine from this popular social media
app rob
that's right brian and even the white
house is aware of the power of tick tock
holding special briefings for some of
its most popular tick tock influencers
significant breaking news this morning
the capital of ukraine kiev survived a
non-stop attack by russian forces
overnight hello from ukraine everybody
woke up to some sad but unsurprising
news there has been another attack from
the russian-controlled occupied
territories of
[Music]
me
[Music]
and we're joined now by one of those
so-called tick-tock influencers aaron
parnez who is also a lawyer in miami
aaron thank you so much for being here
what have you been doing during the
course of this war
yeah and thank you so much for having me
uh
so first off my i have family in ukraine
right now i have an uncle an aunt and a
little cousin there and the night the
invasion occurred i went live and we got
hundreds of thousands of folks on there
watching the live
um and instantly my tick tock account
and my platform really blew up allowing
me to continue to spread this just
reporting about what's happening on the
ground so more folks know and understand
what ukrainians are going through how
many followers do you have now
i have 1.2 million followers right now
and it's mostly those under the age of
30 years old who every morning they go
on tick-tock for an hour every night
they go on tick-tock for an hour before
going to bed and instead of having to
watch cnn for an hour to get your
information and you can watch five tick
tocks for five minutes and get
everything you need to know and be
updated the current situation in ukraine
is dire my family is there including my
57 year old uncle my aunt and my
nine-year-old cousin
so i posted at the beginning of the war
a video of my little cousin my
nine-year-old cousin who was at the time
was in kiev and was sleeping under a
makeshift bed um in a bathtub with a
mattress overhead um and i posted the
video to kind of show folks what it's
like to be living in a war zone right
now and that video
has over four million views now
and it really gave people an insight
into what was happening in the first
couple weeks of the war
the white house took time to try to
brief or to encourage you and others on
tick tock so i just got off of a zoom
call with the white house about the
situation in ukraine i had the
opportunity to ask the white house why
gas down the street is seven dollars and
here's what they said hey folks so i
just had the pleasure of joining a white
house briefing with a senior official
from the national security council what
was that like
it was a fantastic experience it was as
though we you watch a regular press
briefing on tv with jen saki um it was
very similar to that just on zoom with
about 29 other creators and me
and
they for the first 15 minutes or so they
briefed us on what the united states is
doing to help european allies and then
the remaining 30 minutes we were able to
ask questions like journalists
about concepts that our viewers or
questions that our viewers wanted
answers to so you're spending most of
the day doing this
i block out about 10 minutes every hour
to make videos to make content and posts
yes what kind of reaction you're getting
from your followers and has there been
any sort of reaction from the russian
side any attempts to try to stop you
definitely um i get comments almost
every day
on every video from pro-russian bots or
pro-russian accounts um whether it's
spreading russian propaganda and
conspiracy theories for example like um
that there are bioweapons labs in
ukraine or whether it's just folks
commenting
i'm pro-russia i support russia it
happens every day um but my videos
aren't necessarily meant to change
someone's mind my videos are more meant
to spread accurate information and if
accurate information changes someone's
mind then that's for the better but i
don't necessarily throw my opinion into
these videos for that reason
from what we can see you have been very
supportive of president biden's handling
of the war
yes 100
i do think there are things that we can
be doing more i think we need to be
providing um more military assistance in
terms of newer
military capabilities to ukraine but
with that being said i think we've
provided
billions of dollars of united states
military aid already he's provided he's
um solidified the nato alliance more so
than
it's been solidified since the end of
the cold war um i think he's done a
fantastic job both through his rhetoric
and through his actions ironically aaron
parnez's father lev was one of the men
who worked with rudy giuliani to try to
use ukraine to dig up dirt on joe biden
during the election
there is now a guilty verdict against
former rudy giuliani associate lev
parnus parnes has been found guilty of
federal campaign finance criminal
charges prosecutors accused parnis of
hatching a scheme to funnel millions of
dollars in funds from a wealthy russian
financier in the u.s elections lev
parnez has now been convicted of at
least six federal felony counts the most
recent one a fraud charge he pleaded
guilty to last week well my father and i
are
have the same position uh today as it
comes to ukraine where um he grew up
there um he taught he told me a lot
about what it was like growing up there
um
and listen
what's happening today is no one ever
could have imagined um that we would see
ukraine under attack like we do now um
including many folks
my family who grew up there um so it's
it's
different times um different positions
and um i love my father but i'm not my
father what do you mean by that
meaning that i i should be judged for my
own actions and judge should be judged
for my own opinions and for the content
that i produce none of this relates to
my family or to my father in particular
it's all me
have you been distressed to see his
legal troubles
of course um of course i have um just
like any son would um and it's
definitely very difficult um
not many people realize the effects that
um these types of legal proceedings have
on families because there are plenty
plenty of secondary effects so yeah it's
been very difficult so finally how do
you what do you think is next in this uh
invasion of ukraine i think that they
want to end this war by may 9th which is
the day that uh russia celebrates their
win over nazi germany and i think that
they're going to do anything to um claim
victory by then whether that's um
claiming victory that hey we've
liberated a small part of ukraine or
we've taken over all ukraine completely
wherever they are by then i think that's
what they're going to just claim victory
over and try to move on so that's what i
see
from what you can tell finally uh is the
will of the ukrainian people to fight
still holding
100 100 without a doubt um the ukrainian
people are strong the ukrainian people
have put up a massive fight thus far and
there are counter offensive measures
being taken every single day taking back
cities
liberating
liberating towns and
um i could i only see that continuing um
as as this momentum kind of builds on
the ukrainian side
and is it your plan to continue your
activities on tick tock until it does
then 100
erin thank you so much for being with us
here tonight thank you so much for
having me
coming up next the yale professors who's
keeping track of american companies that
have and have not pulled out of russia
ceos don't want to be on his bad list
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network